Nancy Pelosi's husband Paul was attacked
in the couple's home early Friday
morning according to the liberal media
the assailant was a far-right Republican
and this is just another episode in a
years-long pattern of right-wing
political violence that threatens the
very foundations of our sacred democracy
but the facts that we know few and hazy
as they are seem to raise some problems
for this narrative for starters the
attacker is reportedly a nudist and hemp
jewelry designer from Berkeley not
exactly the conservative stereotype
second in the police dispatch recording
Paul Pelosi referred to the apparent
Stranger by name and said that he was a
friend of his
third
shouldn't the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and the second person in
line of succession to the presidency
have a couple security guards at the
house at least some cameras and alarms
it's certainly good news that Paul
Pelosi is expected to make a full
recovery but as far as I can tell
and despite the liberal media narrative
that's the one and only thing that's
certain about this story I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday or on Friday rather is
from Mike honcho who says my mom voted
Democrat in 2020 before she died and now
she will continue to I know very spooky
I hope that we don't have any spooky
ghosts uh voting in the midterm
elections next week any sort of fear
that we might but I certainly hope not
in spooky Illinois and spooky
Philadelphia for some reason the dead
people always seem to make it to The
Ballot Box it's not great this Paul
Pelosi story is really weird
because although in the initial reports
said that the assailant is this far
right Ultra Maga conservative whatever
his name is David de Pap to Pape he's a
Berkeley nudist and hemp jewelry
designer he's a former member of the
green party uh
he according to neighbors is a
he's a like a big lib he's a either
outside of the home that he was staying
at there Pride flags and all all sorts
of other stuff and then according to the
police dispatch video we've or audio
rather uh
Paul Pelosi knew the guy
another four car paper already nine ten
two six four zero Broadway Cross of
Scott and Normandy
Fair 14 hour copy RV stated that there's
a mail in the home and that he's going
to wait for his wife are we say that he
doesn't know who the male is that his
name is David and that he is a friend or
if he's having someone confused
he says yeah I'm someone confused so he
says it he doesn't know the person but
he said his name is David and he is a
friend and so the you hear the guy in
the dispatch line yeah I'm somewhat
confused I think we're all uh somewhat
confused then according to reports an
unidentified person let law enforcement
into the Pelosi home that's kind of
weird uh then also I know
number of politicians who are way less
prominent and powerful than Nancy Pelosi
and a lot of them have security guards
at their homes
especially around election time
especially when threats are a little
higher so it's pretty weird to me that
there was no security whatsoever at the
home of the Speaker of the House
presumably she's got some cameras
everybody's got security cameras now so
if she does
presumably that footage would be very
very helpful how did the guy get in in
the first place I'm not saying that it
can't happen
the story as it's being reported in CNN
it couldn't be totally legit because
some of the facts really don't add up at
all it could be mostly legit though I'm
not saying it can't it's just that a lot
of it doesn't really add up and so as
always when this story broke there were
two reactions
there was the reaction of the the really
emotive kind of people I'm talking two
reactions on the right of the center and
on the right where people rush they say
this is terrible this is awful the right
Wingers have gone too far we need to get
back to some semblance of Civility in
this country what's happened these
far-right Maga people and they just they
rush to to judgment and they immediately
buy the media narrative and they rush to
condemn their own side the right wing
they they totally bought Hook Line and
Sinker that this guy is a right winger
that's one reaction and then there was
the other reaction which is
wait for the details
we know Paul Pelosi were told as he's
going to make a good recovery okay great
that's wonderful that's that's the good
news okay now all the rest of it let's
wait for the story to shake out and so I
am almost always in the ladder Camp I
never rush right away to reaction with
these stories and it's because I learned
the lesson that the media always lie and
especially right before election season
the media really go into Ultra lying
mode and and so you've just got to wait
for that to shake out and and I think
the people who reacted right away
and said no this is this is the worst
thing ever and this is obviously the
Republicans and we've got to stop it we
need to get they just haven't learned
that lesson they haven't learned the
lesson to just chill out I remember
during the Trump years this was a key
issue you'd see some big headline Donald
Trump eats babies and then there would
be this Rush by people even on the right
to say well I condemn this I disavow
this please I'm this is not my party
plain you think guys you need the
24-hour rule okay because whatever the
media are reporting that's almost a
guarantee that it's not true by the very
fact that the media are reporting it
and they're they're really pushing this
narrative here Joe Biden said that the
guy who who went was it found in the
Pelosi home is uh basically a January
sixth insurrectionist
you know uh
it's reports that the same chant
was used by this guy they have in
custody
that was used on January 6th in the
attacks on the U.S Capitol I'm not
making this up this is reported I can't
guarantee it I can tell you what's being
reported
the chant was
where's Nancy where's Nancy where's
Nancy
this is Despicable
there's no place in America
there's too much violence political
violence
too much hatred
too much vitriol
too much political violence too much
hatred this is the man who just gave a
speech in front of an infernal red
backdrop calling half the country
fascists whose very existence poses a
threat to our sacred democracy we need
to be completely written out of politics
this is the man whose party has not only
called for but enacted political
violence for years now which burned half
the country down in 2020 where Chuck
Schumer we're talking about major
Democrats here Chuck Schumer called and
said watch out Justice Gorsuch watch out
Justice Kavanaugh we're coming for you
we're going to unleash the Whirlwind
Hillary Clinton says you can't be civil
with your political opponents Maxine
Waters says you got to push back on
Republicans when you find them in public
spaces and tell them they're not wanted
here and then go to their homes where
their children sleep and yell outside of
their Windows this is the Democrat Party
that that was protesting illegally
outside of the the Supreme Court
Justices homes after they illegally
leaked the the Supreme Court decision in
the Dobbs case and then one of these
people went and tried to assassinate
Brett Kavanaugh this is the party where
after their foot soldiers went out and
and burned things down and killed people
and looted and rioted where the sitting
Vice President of the United States
right now Kamala Harris bailed them out
of jail bailed the violent people out of
jail and were staffers for Joe Biden
himself sent out that same bail link to
bail out the writers to get him back on
the street to commit more violence
against Republicans it's just complete
BS it's so disingenuous I don't want to
hear a word from Joe Biden on political
violence and by the way in this case
he's trying to pretend that the guy who
was found in Pelosi's home in the middle
of the night that he is some right-wing
insurrectionist Maga January 6th there
well the neighbors of this guy say that
that story doesn't make any sense
okay but so the last time you saw was a
couple weeks ago yeah and he was here
for a few days yes okay anything strange
about him or anything that stood up
there's something strange about the
whole household the entire household is
very very strange how about him um uh he
is birds of a feather with a Akin to
them so they are just you know nudist
drug abusers and that's who gravitates
toward them and the children I'm sorry
the children who live there they seem to
be underage or under under 18. Steve I'm
not sure how old they are okay and
Trisha again what's the what do you say
their politics are
um I'm not sure I would imagine that
they're more left-leaning uh because of
their support for uh um the gay
community
um and for uh I'm sorry for other people
but uh it is uh now I'm not sure what
ways they leave because because they
have the flag the LGBT flag yeah
not exactly the portrait of the the
January 6th or the Maga Republican that
that doesn't add up at all then you add
on to this the fact that Paul Pelosi has
been in the news recently for his
personal troubles uh Paul Pelosi drunk
drove his car and then crashed it and
then they tried to bury this in the news
but eventually came out and he was
eventually charged with it so all of
that to say who knows this could be
completely random maybe this guy this
this guy who was found in the pelosium
did have a political change of heart
maybe he did consider himself right wing
even though the rest of the story
doesn't quite seem seem to point to that
maybe this maybe he was looking for
Nancy Pelosi maybe all of that is true
but given given every single thing that
we know about this incident and Paul
Pelosi and the attacker and the family
and everything
we can ER we can urge caution here I
think that would be the responsible
thing to do and especially knowing that
the media lie about everything
especially in the run-up to elections
probably the the safest and smartest bet
here when you're looking at this story
is to approach it with a very healthy
degree of skepticism and independent
thought to try to figure out the details
ourselves because right now they just
don't add up but the one thing I think
we can conclude from the story is that
it's very important to protect your home
which is why you got to check out ring
head on over to ring.com It's a
Wonderful Time of Year fall has so many
wonderful things to enjoy not just
pumpkin spice lattes the kids are back
in school the chaos of Summer travel has
come to an end you can get back into the
swing of things and for many of us
Autumn means it's a very busy time work
school sports clubs you may find
yourself away from home more often than
not which is why I have decided to team
up with a ring with ring security
products you can rest easy knowing that
your home and family are safe when
you're not there the ring doorbell
notifies you when guests or packages
arrive Rings indoor cameras let you keep
an eye on kids and pets while you're
away ring alarm will alert you of any
motion detection while the house is
empty plus if you add smart lighting
around your home you can turn lights on
and off while you're away very very
handy head on over to ring.com to find
out how you can live a little more
stress-free this season with a ring
product that is right for you that is
ring.com I just don't want to hear one
peep from Democrats on political
violence all these Republicans they're
committing political I don't want to
hear one peep Republicans commit
statistically zero political violence
Democrats commit statistically all of
the political violence in the country
and openly call for it and encourage it
from the highest levels of political
power and you're seeing right now a lot
of them are just look like such complete
freaking Hypocrites one of the greatest
Twitter accounts is defiant owls which
just binds Libs
who who are engaged in rank hypocrisy
where they they'll they'll they'll be
saying one thing now you know we need to
disavow political violence and then you
look back even six months and they've
got another tweet mocking some political
violence against conservatives
here's one there's a character who is
just a social media personality I don't
think he's ever done anything of note in
his own life outside of the internet but
he's he's become a you know kind of
popular blue check on the left Brooklyn
dad defiant and so Brooklyn dad defiant
tweets out in response to the Pelosi
attack the violent heinous attack on
Paul Pelosi the speaker's husband needs
to be denounced in the strongest
possible terms by both sides he was
attacked with a hammer ffs
oh okay yeah yeah sure that that seems
like a reasonable thing to say right
it does yeah you want it you don't want
anyone to be attacked even if the guy is
married to the wicked witch from the
West you don't want you don't want
anyone to be attacked with a hammer in
his home
but then Brooklyn dad defiant tweeted
out on May 12 2020. I think Dr Anthony
fauci could probably pick up where Rand
Paul's neighbor left off and nobody
would mind at all
but we need to come on you these awful
Republicans they make light of political
violence
we need to on both sides we need to
return to civility oh yeah the neighbors
should have finished off Rand Paul
that's right by the way you remember
that no one even remembers that now
we're all talking about the Paul Pelosi
attack Rand Paul was attacked in his
home the guy the neighbor almost killed
Rand Paul Rand Paul was in the hospital
broken ribs all kinds I think he had a
collapsed lung if I'm if I'm remembering
correctly remember that no that doesn't
matter
remember when when the lib almost
murdered Steve scalise and Rand Paul
actually on the Congressional baseball
field remember that one oh no that one
that's completely covered up
all of the political violence against
the the conservatives gets covered up
John pavlovitz who's a a big lib
Politico he tweets out the attack on
Paul Pelosi is the direct result of fox
news's in the gop's purposefully
irresponsible rhetoric it will continue
to get worse and if it gets control of
Congress or he clearly also doesn't
quite understand how grammar works but
that's okay we'll we assume that the
libs are illiterate if it gets control
of Congress our nation will be
unrecognizable we need to vote these
monsters into Oblivion
now what does he tweet on May 13 2020
there you have it I get Rand Paul's
neighbor
well rhetoric by the way have you heard
any have you heard of one single
Republican or conservative say yeah Paul
Pelosi got what he deserved yeah get him
again bring a bigger Hammer next have
you heard any of that I haven't heard
that all I've heard from conservatives
as always is oh I hope he gets better
that's okay that's good that he's safe
you know he I might not agree with his
politics but he's a fellow human that's
all I've heard
that's not all I heard when they almost
killed Rand Paul though I heard the libs
celebrating and gefong and cheering and
then this is the funniest one of all
Christine Pelosi Christine Pelosi March
22nd 2020 obviously Christine Pelosi uh
the Pelosi's daughter uh very upset that
her father was attacked
and then Christine Pelosi March 22nd
2020 Rand Paul's neighbor was right okay
so there you have it I don't
I don't even care
to do this game of could you imagine if
the shoe were on the other foot can you
imagine what the media would say if yeah
right could you if if my aunt had
testicles she would be my uncle could
you imagine these hypotheticals that
could never possibly happen oh yes
wouldn't wouldn't if everything were
totally different wouldn't things be
totally different yes I only I only
mention it to point out you shouldn't
take the bait don't take the bait don't
let the libs pressure you into
disavowing the right
and conceding that our rhetoric actually
has been a little and you know Trump's
tweets have been a little edgy and no it
no no not even close
not even close all of the violence is
from the left statistically none of the
violence is from the right statistically
all of the heinous reactions to
celebrate political violence from the
left virtually none of them from the
right
move on we can just move on say a prayer
for Paul Pelosi that he recovers which
you've probably done already and then
move on okay
the smart Democrats understand this
smart Democrats understand that they are
very weak on this issue and that they
look like huge Hypocrites and and so
what they're trying to do now
is not just blame the Republicans I'm
saying the smart Democrats there aren't
a ton of those left in political office
but they're not trying to say this is
all the Republicans fault and this is
they're the ones pushing political
violence because they remember BLM and
they remember antifa and they remember
all of it so now what they're saying is
you know look it's it's happening a
little bit on both sides yes I grant
it's happening we we've been
irresponsible to Democrats but but the
Republicans are just much much worse and
so this is what you're hearing from the
head of D Triple C this would be Sean
Maloney
he's a Democrat Congressman he's an old
Clinton guy
been a Democrat Party operative going
back to the 90s he he actually now
represents my old District where I grew
up
I've worked on Races against John
Patrick Maloney he whatever you want to
say about the guy he is pretty
intelligent uh he's he's trying to
thread a needle right now especially
because he's in a district that has gone
Republican before he could lose his seat
the head of the Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee could actually be
booted out of Congress I think that
would be the first time that that ever
happened and so he's trying to walk this
middle line and now he's saying
uh yes maybe we have some responsibility
but really when you really think about
it it's mostly the Republicans
what's different is when a president for
the first time in our history says he
was cheated out of the results when he
knows that's a lie so let's let's not
let's not let's not pretend for a minute
that both sides have the same same
amount of accountability for for the
loss of confidence in our elections one
side has been out there for a couple of
years now doing everything they can to
pretend Joe Biden didn't win fair and
square when he did and that's the
difference
sure one side has been out there for a
couple of years now questioning our
elections
and the other side has been out there
for a couple of decades now questioning
our elections that's the difference Sean
the Republicans over the last couple of
years because Democrats rigged the 2020
election and it was the craziest
election in our lifetime and in the
weeks and months before the election
they changed all the election rules in
some cases illegally
in some cases in violation of a state
constitution like in Pennsylvania and so
the Republicans reacted that and said
hey you guys cheated and then the the
libs actually went out in a very lengthy
essay in Time Magazine and said here's
how we rigged the election in 2020.
here here we're actually admitting that
we did that so yes you're right for two
years conservatives have been
questioning the legitimacy of our
elections
Democrats have been doing that for at
least two decades more than two decades
they did it with the 2000 election
some even did it with the 2004 election
I'm talking about members of Congress
some they obviously did it with the 2016
election Hillary as far as I can tell
still hasn't really conceded that
election
Stacy Abrams is still doing that with
the 2018 election the list goes on and
on
so you're right you're right Sean let's
not pretend that Republicans and
Democrats share equal responsibility for
denying elections and and for for uh
reducing the trust that we have As
Americans in our institutions right the
Democrats Bear all their responsibility
Republicans bear basically none of it at
all it's it is all the Democrats fault I
don't want to sound reductionist or
partisan or anything but it's just
it's just a fact it's not even close you
look at violence it's not even close the
responsibility that the Democrats have
for violence compared to the Republicans
you look at election denial or whatever
on every measure it's not even close
speaking of
the Liberals denying reality
there's that fellow Dylan Mulvaney Dylan
Mulvaney is a transvestite sort of guy
he uh
he is now become a major sensation in
his own right he's interviewed the
president for goodness sakes and no one
knew who he was before I don't know like
two months ago and now he's everywhere
and now he's getting a corporate
sponsorships and your kids are
definitely seeing him and the guys just
on every screen everywhere and I I think
Dylan Mulvaney actually the silver
lining of this transgender Madness Dylan
Mulvaney is actually showing
what lies at the root of not just the
transgender issue but so much of this
modern chaos that we find ourselves in
it was one Dylan Mulvaney video that
proved this to me and it it's the sort
of thing I'm gonna have to show it to my
family around uh Thanksgiving and you
know when I ca I'm always so excited to
prepare that Thanksgiving turkey before
I do that I got to call cinch head on
over to cinch.com use promo code Knowles
okay before you pull out that turkey
fryer you've got to give cinch a call
cinch is a propane grill tank Home
Delivery Service they deliver propane
tanks right to your door cinch delivers
on your schedule there's no long-term
commitment or subscription required plus
delivery is completely contactless you
don't have to be home to receive the
delivery you can track the order on the
Cinch app from anywhere are you looking
to exchange a tank cinch handles that
whole process for you so you don't have
to go to the hardware store or gas
station you can exchange any brand of
tank as long as it is standard Grille
size you choose your delivery date cinch
handles the rest so right now you go
online to cinch.com or download their
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just ten dollars
with promo code nulls kwles
that is cinch.com or you can download
the Cinch app use promo code nulls to
get your first tank exchange for just 10
bucks
c-y-n-c-h.com promo code Knowles this is
a limited time offer and you must live
within a cinch service area to redeem it
visit cinch.com offer for details Dylan
Mulvaney
the man who pretends to be a girl on
social media has gone corporate he's now
Shilling an ad for instacart note to
self never use instacart again and in
this advertisement for instacart I think
he accidentally shows you
what lies at the heart of basically all
of our modern political problems
instacart that y'all can shop to get my
dream sleepover experience
speaking of my order is here
I have the delivery first things first
skin care and I'm warning you beforehand
I eat mostly junk food but we're having
a sleepover so it's allowed
it's hot it's hot I still have room in
my dessert stomach so we're having ice
cream
I think we start with prank calls and
then put a finger down then we'll go
around and manifest all of our dreams
and goals for the rest of the year then
a rom-com and then we can paint our
nails and we're gonna stay up all night
long visit the link in my bio to shop
Dylan's sleepover Essentials via
instacart now
so everybody's focusing on one that this
guy's now got a corporate sponsorship
that's the that's one level of analysis
or they'll focus on this guy he's just
doing a caricature of of you know a sort
of 90s sitcom gay man or a ridiculous
cartoon of what men think women are like
and it's just that's so offensive and
he's wearing women's face and this is
okay that's another level of analysis
that's not what caught my attention one
word caught my attention in that video
manifest
did you hear that in between the popcorn
and the rom-com and it he said we're
going to manifest our futures together
we're going to manifest our Destinies
and then we're going to do
remember manifest or not manifest
destiny that would be pretty cool
actually uh you know we're going to
manifest our dreams and desires
that word manifest is the language of
New Age occultism
it's it's a very
weird kind of demonic idea that you can
make yourself into a sort of a God and
make demands on God himself and demands
on the entire universe and that it will
just happen this is what you see in that
book The Secret and in lots of kind of
weird new agey self-help Oprah kind of
stuff
is this idea that you're really a Divine
you're the Divine spirit and if you just
if you just believe enough in your own
power and the power of your your
Consciousness and your energy you can
make the universe do whatever you want
and it's it's a cult and it's demonic
and it made me realize oh you know what
all of this is about you know what all
of this is about it's not about the
second wave feminists and it's not about
the rise of this particular ideology or
this particular time it's not about you
know the the critical theory Department
of the you know it's you know what it's
about
it's it's because people aren't getting
baptized
so what I know I know Media Matters is
going to clip this out good I hope you
do clip this out because I want people
to hear this
why is all why is the world getting so
insane right now
I think once you get past all the layers
of the economic analysis and the
political ideological you know it's
because
public religion is on the decline people
are not getting baptized and so they're
not during baptism during traditional
right of baptism
three exorcisms are performed on the
person being baptized to cast out the
demons that prowl about the world
seeking the ruin of souls because this
is a very Fallen World and uh this is a
wonderful thing and then you get the
demons cast out of you and you don't
need to worry about this stuff as much
anymore well now people aren't being
baptized and the demons are just running
amok this stuff the Dylan Mulvaney stuff
the transgender stuff it's just demonic
think about furries have you heard of
furries you know furries are these
people who have this weird sexual fetish
where they think that they're basically
possessed by the spirits of animals
that's just Demons What do you call what
would you if you went back in a time
machine
500 years and you were talking to Ye
Olde Johnny Smith down the street
and you said oh hi there Mr Smith yeah
I'm from the future and I'm actually I'm
something called a furry he says what's
a furry lad and I don't know I don't
know why he's Irish and and you say oh
furry well you see I'm I am actually I
know I look like a human but I'm
actually the spirit of an animal and
that's really what animates me and so
I'm really a chipmunk and that's that's
my true Spirit he'd look at you probably
a little wacky and he'd say oh you're
possessed by a demon lady you know go
get down to the local priest and get
exercise these people
who say that not only are they one
gender but they're multiple genders in
their heads we've we've played this
these clips on the show of people who
say I've got these head mates these head
partners and they're all these different
personalities in my head so one day I'm
a boy one day I'm a girl one depending
on who's kind of in control of my buddy
what do you call that it's just demons
man it's just demons like I and I know
that people are going to look at me like
I'm crazy when I say that but what is
crazier
because for all of human history every
single place in the world including in
Christendom and every Pagan culture
everywhere forever
everyone has had some sense that there
is not only a physical world but a
spiritual world and that some Spirits
are good and some Spirits are bad and
the bad spirits are demons and they do
weird stuff to humanity okay everyone
for all of human history has thought
that until about five minutes ago in our
stupid atheist civilization and now our
explanation for these phenomena is that
actually boys can secretly be girls and
sometimes people actually are animated
by the spirits of chipmunks and that
actually if you believe enough in your
Consciousness and your energy you can
make the universe Bend toward your
specific will through manifesting
through the secret and the Oprah book
love and the some of the most popular
media out there which which is crazier
obviously the modern stuff is crazier
I know that it seems like really
simplistic political analysis to say
that the cure for these problems is to
just go and get baptized but that is if
people why did this stuff go away in the
Middle Ages in ancient Pagan cultures
you had you had furries okay in ancient
Pagan cultures you had something akin to
transgenderism and people just feeling
that they were possessed by all sorts of
spirits why did it largely go away
throughout Christendom
I know the atheists and the Liberals and
the rationalists are not going to
believe me it's because people were
baptized and because the demons were not
allowed to run amok but they are now and
that's very bad and we should strongly
discourage it okay Dylan Mulvaney he
definitely needs a psychologist but he
he more than that even he really needs a
priest speaking of casting out demons
the new Chief twit the new head of
Twitter Elon Musk
has reportedly had Tesla Engineers lock
down the Tesla software code so he comes
in he's carrying his sink into Twitter
headquarters and he takes over and he
decapitates the Twitter leadership and
he fires the CEO Brad agrawal and he
fires that awful woman who censored
Donald Trump and he fires the head legal
counsel
sends them all packing and then
according to reports he locks the
Twitter Engineers out of the code
which is a really good sign because that
means that his own Engineers can go in
and audit it and see what is going on
with the algorithm since Elon Musk took
over you have maybe noticed if you're on
Twitter a spike in your followers and
for those of us who are in the media or
in politics where we have just by virtue
of our jobs we have bigger follower
accounts I think I've gained something
like 50 000 followers since Elon Musk
took over so clearly something is going
on at Twitter right now and every
conservative just about is seeing a
spike at least a relative spike in not
only follows but also
engagement
so what is going on yeah we know that
the libs
had their thumb on the scales they had
their boot on the scales and they were
they were tilting the Public Square
against conservatives against what
normal people want in favor of these
lunatics in favor of people like Dylan
Mulvaney and transgenderism and open
borders and the Democrats all all of
which the issues and the people have
very low public approval ratings but
nonetheless are disproportionately
promoted on Twitter and then they
partner with these fake fact checking
websites like Snopes and PolitiFact
which just published left-wing opinion
pieces as though they're the gospel
truth and then based on those left-wing
opinion pieces they censor conservatives
on issues like covid on issues like the
elections and so forth so and they do
this all obviously with the support of
the establishment media which just got
totally trolled by conservatives
specifically with regard to Twitter take
a listen to this interview with
apparently fired Twitter employees
outside of headquarters
I mean a free speech is you know Nazis
saying that uh you know trans women
shouldn't you know use women's uh locker
rooms then awesome I guess mission
accomplished we'll see listen I gotta
touch base with my husband and wife I
gotta get out of here all right thank
you guys
listen I've got to go touch base with my
husband and wife I gotta get out of here
uh that man introduced himself as Daniel
Johnson and presented himself to the
media as a fired uh Twitter engineer
there was another guy who did this his
friend Rahul ligma
and so the two guys together would be
ligma and Johnson
ligma Johnson and the media totally fell
for it the story here the story here is
not that these guys are trolls and they
had a funny line the real story here is
that the media aired that segment the
real story here
is that the media were duped by these
guys even that phrase okay I gotta go
see my husband and wife now
the media are so so far gone in leftist
ideology they probably didn't even bat
an eyelash at that statement every
normal person is doubled over laughing
at that that's so freaking funny but
because it's actually not so far off
from the left's insane ideology they
went along with it the real takeaway
from from that stunt is that
as we have seen time and time again the
people the great bulk of the people have
much much much more common sense
they have common sense and the liberal
ruling class does not
you know we launched Jeremy's razors
just a few months ago we've already
taken millions of dollars away from woke
razor companies that hate you and use
that money to better support what you
believe in but the time has come for
Jeremy's razors to look Inward and
conduct a totally legit not at all
Hollow or contrived Dei audit of
ourselves so here it is
or Jeremy's razors diverse no the razors
are great we don't need to make
different ones or Jeremy's razor is
Equitable well yes when you buy a
Founder's kit Equity is transferred away
from your pocket and into Jeremy's and
lastly our Jeremy's razors inclusive
well of course they are they include
blades so there you have it Jeremy's
razors is now Dei self accredited and
still the only Razer brand that actually
upholds virtue instead of merely
signaling it today you can get 40 off
your founder series shave kit when you
go to jeremy'sraisers.com that's
Jeremy's razors.com
speaking of a lack of Common Sense
a Starbucks employee has gone viral
For Whining in the back room about how
tough the job is
people wonder why we need a union at
Starbucks and I
am literally about to quit like I I
don't know if I'm gonna do it but like I
really want to I almost walked out today
and I'm crying in the bathroom right now
and I must cut on the floor it's just
as a full-time student I get scheduled
for 25 hours a week and then on weekends
they schedule me the entire day open to
close up on the schedule for eight and a
half
hours
both Saturday and Sunday I'm like three
and a half hours into my shift there's
so many customers and we have four
people on the floor all day
and then people are yelling at me
because I don't have their orders ready
because I don't know what to do
and a customer was misgendering me today
like really badly I didn't have their
order ready and so they were just like
totally talking like each other and
they're like she's clearly incompetent I
have a full mustache and beard
foreign
ever since he brought up the issue of
misgendering I actually don't know I
don't know what gender he is so I'll use
he which is the gender neutral singular
pronoun
he's very upset because he has to work
sometimes 25 hours a week
sometimes he has to work a full shift
a full shift being
eight and a half hours
how many how many people
only work eight hours a day
even maybe you work eight hours a day at
your job but then
I I know very few people who can get by
working just eight hours a day or even
who want to only work eight hours a day
I'm being told by the way by the
producers that the the video is of a of
a woman who I guess is taking hormones
and it's very it was a little tough to
tell because the the it's so zoomed in
tight on her face that you can't quite
get a picture of the whole body and
height and everything to see uh what sex
she is so she's obviously
a troubled person she's obviously got a
severe mental illness she probably
should be in a therapist's office rather
than trying even to work a job she's
obviously not capable of working a job
but it actually raises a lesson for all
of us in society
not not just the ones who are kind of
crazy and think we're the opposite sex
and the you know spoiled snowflake young
people who you know never had to work a
tough job in their life or whatever for
all of us we have a lesson here
this woman should be very thankful to
Starbucks
for presenting her with hardship and
giving her an opportunity to mature
and giving her an opportunity to do a
difficult thing working at Starbucks
actually is a difficult job you gotta
I've worked I've worked in fast food
I've worked at restaurants I've worked
plenty of service jobs it can be very
tough it's very demanding customers can
be tough you got to do things a mile a
minute especially at the lunch rush or
the afternoon Coffee Rush so yeah I'm
sure it's a tough job and the main thing
the main takeaway that this young lady
should find in this year is
to stop complaining
stop complaining it is it is such a gift
and and for everybody in life to face
hardship and then not complain
and suffer in silence and cultivate a
spirit of resignation and patience and
fortitude all of which are virtues that
are completely forgotten in our I'm
getting so angry I'm gonna throw my
microphone off here that are completely
forgotten in our decadent modern culture
it's really it's wonderful that will
that will make you a stronger person it
will make you a better person it'll make
you a Holier person if you do that
you don't need to whine about every
problem in fact you should never whine
ever about anything
you can engage in criticism especially
if that criticism can be effective I
mean that's what the show is right we're
criticizing the modern culture but not
we're not criticizing it from the
perspective of things are so bad right
now I hate it isn't this a terrible
world no quite the opposite we're saying
this is what's bad here's how we got to
fix it this is what we got to stop doing
this is what we got to start doing here
is this is this is not working as well
as it should right now here's a better
policy to put in its place that's that's
a wonderful thing fixing things is a
wonderful thing
but but whining and complaining and
saying woe is me you should never say
that excise that from your vocabulary
because we all make fun of that chick at
Starbucks
we are all we have all been that chick
at some point in our lives
we have especially me because I can't
really grow a beard that well so you
know it's pretty patchy actually not so
different you know especially today that
I'm in my Rachel Maddow costume for
Halloween
we
have all been that chick at some point
and then I hope most of us have grown up
and learn to not we're living in a time
when we're told don't repress anything
don't know you've got to let it all out
you've just got to don't talk about your
feelings when when you complain when you
whine you put burden on other people
you there's a study about this there was
a study it just came out I just saw this
in the Drudge Report so you know take it
with a grain of salt but it's citing
real academics here
that stress spreads like a virus from
people to people
the neuroscientist Tom Tony W Buchanan
who's a professor at St Louis University
measured the response of people who were
simply observing stress in others and he
found that the observer's cortisol
levels spiked via a phenomenon known as
stress contagion the spread of stress
from person to person like a virus and
we all know anecdotally that this is
true
we all know that this is true
because we if you've ever had a sort of
difficult relative or you know a friend
who's just constantly whining about
everything you know it puts you on edge
as well and I wonder too as I say the
chief cause of all of our ills in the
modern age is not some political
philosopher or some government
bureaucrat or some stupid policy or
something it's that people are not
getting baptized and so demons are
running amok at because we don't have
enough exorcisms going on it's just a
fact okay we say hard facts on this show
that's one of them but another cause of
so much of the disorder I wonder if it's
because we have these social media feeds
feeds right we're just constantly
feeding ourselves like horses with a
slot bag on except we're feeding
ourselves images and and uh audio and
and videos and things like that and so
much of that content
is really angry stressful content where
it's you know the transgender person
yelling and screaming and you know it's
the even people on the right often do
this I sometimes fear that I will I will
never have a career in political
commentary I guess I do have one but in
the long run because I can't get angry
I get angry like twice a year and most
political commentary is someone sort of
just shaking their fist at the screen or
yelling into a microphone I just can't
do that I'm not that angry I'm dismayed
at the state of the world I would like
to turn things around I got some ideas
on how to do that
but I just because it's just it's just
rude to be angry and whining and
complaining all the time and it shows
that you're not in control of your
emotions and it shows that you haven't
cultivated a higher will and it shows
that you're still given to your base
passions don't do it don't be like that
chick at Starbucks folks let me yell
that into the microphone don't be like
that chicken Starbucks because it will
make you very unhappy and it will make
the people around you very unhappy as
well now speaking of whining
penguin Random House
is uh potentially going to cancel a book
that they're doing with Amy Coney
Barrett why on Earth would a major
publisher cancel a book that is written
by a Justice on the Supreme Court well
because hundreds of penguin Random House
staffers and other literary
professionals
feel that it's it's wrong for penguin to
publish her book they say this is not
just a book that we disagree with and we
are not calling for censorship many of
us work daily with books we find
disagreeable to our personal politics
rather this is a case where a
corporation is privately funded the
destruction of human rights with obscene
Prophets
Coney Barrett is free to say as she
wishes but penguin Random House must
decide whether to fund her position at
the expense of human rights in order to
inflate its bottom line or to truly
stand behind the values it proudly
espouses to hold
what are they saying they're saying it's
because of Dobbs it's because the
Supreme Court said that there's no
constitutional right to kill hundreds of
thousands of babies a year which is
obviously the case and you know the
states now can decide whether they want
to kill babies or not they're saying
this is a violation penguin random ass
is funding the obliteration of Human
Rights so one the book is obviously
happening after the Dobbs decision
so they they're just even getting their
timeline wrong they wouldn't be funding
and Amy Coney Barrett gets a very nice
salary as a federal judge so it's not
funding any sort of decision but what
this is about
this is about an idea that the left has
has promulgated in recent years which is
everything I don't like is a violation
of Human Rights
everything I don't like
it needs to be booted from the Public
Square it can't even be discussed it's a
violation of Human Rights
and they use human rights to describe
everything truly everything that they
want is a human right getting your
genitals lopped off because you have a
fantasy that's now a human right
forget about 10 years ago 15 years ago
they would say Health Care is a human
right again I don't know exactly what
that means but now they've taken it to
the around truly to the realm of the
Absurd where they're saying lopping off
my genitals is a human right and getting
you to pay for it and killing my baby
that's a human right
and so what's the cure for this because
in a world where
everything is a human right then nothing
is a human right right and you can claim
that anything is a human right if you
like it then that phrase doesn't have
any meaning
what is the cure for this
the cure for this is changing our
perspective on the law and even
conservatives are going to have to
change our perspective on the law
right now the libs view the law as just
a weapon to wield to attack or their
political opponents and the right tends
to view the law in this really
reductionist
way which is just the law is exactly
what is written in the text of the
Constitution or the text of the statute
for getting all sorts of context for
getting the debates that led up to the
enactment of that law and forgetting
most importantly the underlying
principles of of justice and the natural
law that undergird the positive law and
you see this especially in the way that
conservatives Now call ourselves
originalists and especially textualists
no the cure for this is to view the law
not as just a bunch of random
preferences that we can enshrine in a
statute
but as an objective reality that we can
know and discover through the use of our
reason because the the civil law derives
from the general principles of the
natural law we know that it is wrong to
commit murder not just because there's a
federal law against it or a state law
against it but because that is a fact of
the objective moral order that we can
know because it is within the natural
law we can know that through the use of
our reason I think we've got to become
much
more confident of that moral view yet
again this comes back to conservatives
need to ditch the you do you kind of
skepticism who who really knows you know
what's good or bad you do what you
you're good might be my bad and my bad
no we got to ditch that nonsense there
is such a thing as good there is such a
thing as bad we can know quite a lot
about that through our reason and our
moral conscience and we need to be able
to articulate that and enforce it
through the law it's the only way out of
of the lib saying everything I want is a
human right and conservatives have
basically nothing to say that to that
these days unless we can acknowledge
that there is an objective reality we
can perceive it and we are going to
enforce that through the law now you
know today enough about the law
today is music Monday baby and so my
producers assure me they've got a
wonderful song for me to listen to to
analyze because I am a hip-hop Maven the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
[Music]